thank you uh Yasser yes we are with
ruian Yen after an important Victory
riank take us through today's game um
um I don't usually Play Bishop C4 but I
prepped this song for her
um and after Bishop C5 C3 Knight F6 D4
ed4 E5 I prepped after takes I pressed
Bishop before Bishop to be foreign
yeah and 92 and almost so she passed
like a long time here I think I think
she was trying like like figure out like
like what is it I kind of like prepped
so I think she was trying to get out of
my preparation I guess and she played
Bishop before before uh yes so Bishop B6
was a new thing for her
did you know anything about the position
well I just knew this like and then
Bishop B3 and Knight D2 but instead of
97 oh I think she should have played
Bishop G4 and I think maybe like Bishop
E2 or I'm not sure
yeah
yeah I I just knew like you know like
Kevin videos
F3 or to go F6 things that yeah yeah so
it's important to set up this bit on the
h5d1 diagonal and she did not
you played uh she did but it was like a
move too late and now Bishop takes F3
doesn't you can take back with the
Knight with the Knight on D2 that makes
sense
and then you got to this position H3
Bishop D4 yeah how did you assess
ment I I calculated like the law of
lines and some are like really weird and
like like I think I like I said Bishop
F4 oh I was talking like Queen D3
um and then Bishop B3 it like takes
takes and then like Bishop H3 like I saw
this and I was like shouted out yeah
that was a shot evaluated like if I had
gone to this position I'd probably
played like Rook at five
but he wanted more yeah
yeah so you found this beautiful move
Bishop to F yeah because I realized her
Knight like she can't stay for night
because the only thing I was saving it
was like attacking the E3 Bishop so I
moved it very nice makes logical sense
of course uh and then he found this yeah
I thought this was really nice because
she had she I always thought I was
calculators during the game and I saw
like all like 984 ideas
like I mean I think this was probably
it's still okay but I didn't want to
like go into this you have to go G3 yeah
this is not yeah it's really risky I I
really like so I I think I thought this
was nice because I kind of pinned her
night and she doesn't have any like yeah
and then
towards the end I think you found a very
nice solution after 38 Rook takes H7
beautiful way to finish things off and
uh right now you're having a pretty
decent event how would you assess it how
would you assess your control so far I
guess the results are fine but the games
yeah uh like my gaming is Savina like
after the game I just cried for like 30
minutes really wow did you analyze with
your coach or yeah no was your coach
mean to you
yeah I didn't want to look at it
thank you very much for joining the show
we'll see you tomorrow through Yang our
congratulations we thought you played a
really really really fine game and
Bishop D7 especially